well guys the second and final major of
the year
is at an end we saw some incredible
counter-strike play and if you do want
to relive those aces those clutches and
those vac worthy plays well we've got
another video just for you it's called
the best of the face at London major but
now that we're a few days out from the
major I think it's about time we relived
some of our favorite fails now rain
along the Mac 7 close quarters though
old pellets it's the question and funny
moments bomb was planted detritus
diffused with the smoke but the that
happened across the pond now let's get
this video started with some very
unfortunate mishaps that happened during
matches in game and who takes it down 8
seconds to plop the ball can they stop
it 5 seconds is up I'm gonna go down in
time what I hope this time here the pond
the bomb
[Applause]
that's much they come through
Oh a Z's gonna get two kills this is so
awkward certainly not kadian shuts him
down
holy [__] just Z what just happened
do we want verses to avoiding the
sixteen and old you definitely don't
want that whatever else happens just
take that little bit of pleasure away
from them still be crouching on in
looking for sip instant headshot just
well enough for the pre we'll take him
down and they make it happen sixteen
knowing MIB are to make it into the
playoffs well I have never seen anything
like it
snacks is coming and all of my say-so if
we look at this time will surely get
caught by snacks oh my god I don't
believe it
track it now still holding off backside
of banana crush wants to work in that
direction and all my goodness 30 degree
window dragon how did that miss that
shaved his pubic hair smoke a ball
Dennis come on this is all right now I'm
starting to actually get concerned so
that was that's just a really bad miss
that got sent to given if he finds one
of these shots publicly don't get both
that's I don't know if I agree with that
he's just playing the time he wants them
to go for the plant right in front but
it's on the other side of the box and
yay fires the gun was completely
surrounded somehow he gets a kill you
cannot follow it up that was a very
panic situation all tests starving each
other as well not expect him to be there
simple even just stopped oh look they're
staring at each other like oh man he's
pissed about that he knows now it's
gotta be that surely he's not that close
there's no way he can get there in five
seconds oh tap hold and wait for care
again but nerves he's on it down around
the corner why'd he go long now simple
gets off it finds the shot yeah I'm so
like is it here did a headshot there so
thanks to Korean it's happening range is
forcing his way in with Carrigan's help
looking for the clutch my goodness my
goodness brain oh my god that's so close
they cuz all know he whipped sleep
through the underarms hand throw up the
a chi and that's gonna cause problems
get right waiting to see how much
pressure will be applied toward mentally
certainly worried but they're on top of
loose based on the trajectory of the
name behind him and that still isn't
enough to take down fur the timing was
so brutal that you get right had his
cross that completely zoned in on the
boost area he drops it down for a second
the check another angle that's unfair
comes on the corner of course now rain
along the max seven close quarters
though all the pellets he misses the
first chance and sip some out dives
under it and that one chance and he
couldn't make it work gonna be going
down that's rain with a head shot him oh
no the missed tap big opportunity there
Dupree gonna try and follow it up a
kerrigan shuts him down D D he wrapped
around it all of a sudden he can't find
it it's up top all they're gonna lose
aren't they
oh no they actually are losing the round
because of it take there's no time oh
[Music]
it's actually a disastrous but they
can't even hide the smiles handing it
right there to show ya they're just so
happy to be here so find it oh hello
that's the must have seen it surely oh
my god oh I'd say hasn't seen it that is
such a small heads but there's there's
12 seconds they haven't got time to
rotate he's just saving his weapon
they've got to go to elimination Jake
this is the weirdest thing ever
[Music]
does he know as a snake he must surely
know at this point oh my god
how enough is this happen vente had
absolutely no idea he was just trying to
save his gun James now it's a two on
three and here on the bomb now rapid
readies out of bullets now try they
can't even make it through the door open
smokes just way too shallow that was
epic recoil wasn't it
that's one okay doesn't count say it if
it gets five girls in this round just
one wish to take methods and he's almost
gonna get it done WP but he's just
having a trouble mentally we'll take him
down six and old at a perfect climbing
now they've got four of those like this
okay so tiny one or two slaps did a
better job in four phase need a
restraining order because that is way
too much harassment from G to keep in
mind ladies and gents at one point this
is twelve one two liquid Oh Justin there
is this the only player to answer back
but he's been destroyed
no what a time to get that happening
though not like this top her it might be
here to fight for this next one I think
they're actually gonna go ruling Oh God
here we go this could change the whole
course the Zeus is out he's rushing it
the best shot and he's trying to dismiss
that person knife he was done for he
hunts it down that was beautiful it just
picks up a Zeus
here we go all rain knows it's coming
out I think there's a single chin Oh
screw you can win this no Johnny this
would be a nice stroll off by the way
and he said first one is the showmatch
he knows that dance towards B but he'll
hear him coming from sure perhaps he
knows it all this is a definite zoo
staff if he gets a Zeus for the ACE
white white James is black yeah he's not
gonna this isn't gonna go well now guys
if you know faceit events then you know
at this major there was no shortage of
silliness dankmemes and chicken
predictions chickens the size of you
James
wait no you have to eat from the bag yes
so whether it's the players or the
broadcast talent here are some of our
favorite hilarious moments from the
faceit London major
[Applause]
yeah many people have been waiting for
this and you guys to rise up once again
to new legends and major status I have
no idea what you said but ghonim yes and
just on a personal level to both of you
and I think you're gonna see a guy
who'll take some inches for no wil will
go the extra inches for you oh really
excited to meet you
parla by the way I just want to talk
about one of those individual moments I
think Deb Fox's 3 K I believe it was on
Brown 24 I think we're here they came
out of the connector
what happens there how did you feel that
that was a turning point for you in that
game the map is just like really
fast-paced and if they just hit your
[__] oh my god come on Jackie meaty
fish Kia's my command upon connect with
Jim Jim Moret card in judo egg rock las
casas a toast
we were owned three on four bomb was
planted they tried to defuse with the
smoke but the coop spray by simple saved
us
I remember is who I think it was like 14
14 or something like that for us and I
had a knife in my hand all the time this
one one but someone wanted to be a
little bit about yeah takedown it felt
really good I had to to skills in him
and he had me one time so I will not
game and I was mad cuz I didn't either
but you know I gotta wind again you play
to win the game well instead have to
wave goodbye unfortunately to space
soldiers 6 to 15 so I hope it comes into
this one angry but it's all team move
need to deliver not just to right
slyboots you should be ashamed of
yourself as smoo you're doing this best
doge impression triple triple word score
and all sorts going live actually just
sitting like some crazy code just to
coordinate the troops oh my goodness
Dupree okay that's very interesting what
does that one mean
[Music]
is wealth okay shut up brain all of my
sister hats lugar and code will make it
through three best of three and like
Rose getting left hanging for Steven off
that he said no I thought he looked a
bit shook up so winter just like a straw
and the door shut
[Music]
you have to find your video call it
inner peace or something like that in a
team and find your bros and learn to
trust in each other when you play the
game that's plays a huge part of it and
we just have to point out offers on
inferno on the T side I could play the
whole thing I can but I can't remember
it that's what you just said James you
listening to yourself
shut up Navi will it be MIB or that
would be could be that my bi could be
face gland you don't know B phase I am I
would assume a rather proud Canadian we
spend our time alone in the dark but
cool there we do we want to take maybe
10 seconds of songs behind hey we do it
I've got the time a lot loaded up here
10 seconds you ready yeah I'm beginning
the time now 10 seconds is longer than
then it seems isn't it it is what is
everything goes quiet yeah okay guys
that's it for the fails and funny
moments from the face at London major
now if you did enjoy this video leave a
like leave a comment subscribe to the
channel and of course tell me what your
favorite funny moment from this major
was and I will see you next time thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button